[Music]  I do love teaching and I mean I'm not  sure if there's anything else I could do  that I would do well I have never not  looked forward to my morning classes at  Hillsdale and I've have always had  morning classes I love getting out of  bed and starting off the day by having  that kind of just great intellectual  engagement with my students no two days  of the same even the same body of  students from one day to another is a  different body of students simply  because we're asking you questions and  we're building off what we had done the  day before one of the reasons I love the  liberal arts is because I've seen the  way that it allows students to really  grow there's an awareness I think that  what they're doing now is important but  it's important within this very large  context of time being with the students  is endlessly rewarding and the fact I  get to walk around and hang out with  these people all the time it's I can't  imagine a better life it's a great life